Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. In der Frauen-Fußball-Liga in den USA wurde kein Spieltag vollzogen. Wie ist es dazu gekommen? Dahinter steckt mehr. Das wollen wir jetzt besprechen mit Jürgen Kalwa in diesem Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Jürgen, schön, dass du mal wieder im Rasenfunk bist. Ja, es ist mal wieder ein aktueller Anlass, warum wir miteinander sprechen. Und vielleicht hat der eine oder andere Hörer und die eine oder andere Hörerin sich gedacht, na gut, was ist denn das für eine Nichtmeldung, dass am Wochenende mal keine Spiele stattgefunden haben in der Frauenfußball-Profiliiga in den USA. Dahinter steckt aber mehr. Was ist denn der Grund dafür, dass sich mehrere hundert Spielerinnen in einem Videocall dazu entschlossen haben, die Spiele zu boykottieren an diesem Wochenende?
Fangen wir erstmal mit der Formalität an, weil sie haben nicht boykottiert, sondern die Liga hat aufgrund der Stimmung unter den Spielerinnen die Spiele selbst dann verlegt. Sie haben nicht genau gesagt, was das jetzt für den Kalender bedeutet. Ich bin auch nicht sicher, dass im Moment irgendjemand genau weiß, wie es jetzt weitergeht. Aber aus arbeitsrechtlichen Gründen hätten die Spieler das nicht boykottieren dürfen oder nicht können. Und die Liga war aber so einverständlich oder verständig, dass sie gesagt haben, okay, das müssen wir ernst nehmen. Es sind ja verschiedene Dinge passiert, unter anderem gleich nach diesem Schwall von Protesten, wurde ja auch die Geschäftsführerin, wir nennen das Commissioner, Frau Bärth, wurde ihres Amtes aus ihrem Amt gejagt. Also sie hat offiziell gekündigt, aber es war völlig klar, dass sie Druck bekommen hatte, und zu gehen, das heißt, solche Dinge sind ja auch noch passiert, und wenn man das noch abrunden will, der Fußballverband, der im Hintergrund bisher nur agierte, hat eine Untersuchung angekündigt, wo eine sehr namhafte ehemalige Justizministerin, nicht die Alte von der FIFA-Geschichte, sondern Sally Yates, die in Trumps Sachen einen Namen gemacht hat, wurde gebeten, sich darum zu kümmern, hat sie zugesagt. Und die Liga hat auch ihr eigenes Untersuchungsgremium irgendwie angeschoben. Das heißt, also all die Dinge sind innerhalb kürzester Zeit passiert. Und wenn wir das ganz schnell abrunden, also in der Timeline, Anfang letzter Woche, Berichterstattung in der Washington Post, da fällt der erste Stein um. Ein Trainer der Mannschaft, Washington Spirit, wird entlassen wegen seines Verhaltens. Und kurz darauf kommt die Athletic, die Internetplattform, mit einer weiteren Geschichte, die zwar länger zurückliegt, aber nie richtig abgehandelt wurde. Und der Trainer, Riley, der jetzt in North Carolina ist, wurde rausgekickt. Und diese Dinge sind innerhalb kürzester Zeit fast wie eine Domino-Anlage, ein Domino-Stein fällt und die anderen fallen mit.
Ja. Und es geht um sexuellen Missbrauch, um emotionale Gewalt. Also man darf jetzt die beiden Fälle nicht miteinander vermischen, aber insgesamt um ein toxisches Klima, in dem die Spielerinnen sich Misshandlungen verschiedenster Art ausgesetzt sehen, was zu eben auch dieser Stärke der Reaktion geführt hat. Lass mal vielleicht mit dem Fall von Paul Riley beginnen. Das war eben das, was The Athletic da aufgedeckt hat. Da geht es um zwei Spielerinnen, die über sexuellen Missbrauch gesprochen haben, auch um einen Ausnutzen seiner Machtposition und nur damit die Hörerinnen und Hörer das einordnen können. Paul Riley ist jetzt nicht irgendein x-beliebiger Trainer, sondern der hat schon richtig viel sportlich gesehen gewonnen. Er hat mehrmals die Meisterschaft gewonnen, hat mehrmals 2017 und 2018 auch den Award des Trainers des Jahres bekommen von der Liga und ihm wurden jetzt verschiedene Dinge vorgeworfen, was auch zu seiner Entlassung geführt hat. Kannst du das einmal kurz für uns zusammenfassen, was ist da aufgedeckt worden von The Athletic?
Also die Vorwürfe der Spielerin, also einer, die sich dann auch getraut hat, in die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen mit mehreren Jahren Verspätung, die bleiben natürlich im Moment erst einmal, das sind Vorwürfe oder Beschuldigungen. Riley selbst hat dem zumindest den Teilen widersprochen. Das heißt, wir wissen nicht genau, was passiert ist, aber wir können von einer Sache ausgehen, dass sich schon früh die Spielerin bereit war, sich gegen dieses System des Vertuschens und der Misshandlung oder des Missbrauchs zu wehren. Und dass es wieder, wie in den anderen Fällen, die wir ja auch schon begleitet haben und kennen, wieder an der Bereitschaft der zuständigen Funktionäre und Verantwortlichen fehlt, diese Dinge dann so ernsthaft voranzubringen, dass die Spielerinnen oder die Athletinnen das Gefühl haben, ihre Interessen werden wahrgenommen von diesen Leuten, für die sie ja arbeiten oder mit denen zusammen sie arbeiten. Und das ist, glaube ich, die Sache, auf die man es wirklich zuführen muss. Es ist kein fußballspezifisches Thema, auch wenn wir hier im Rasenfunk gerne über Fußball reden, sondern es hat was damit zu tun, wo der Sport im Moment insgesamt steht. Es gibt nicht nur Missbrauch von Frauen oder jungen Mädchen, es gibt auch Missbrauch von jungen oder jungen Männern. Aber im Wesentlichen handelt es sich bei den Geschichten, die wir inzwischen kennen, um den Missbrauch von Frauen. Und natürlich, weil Frauen heute im Sport eine viel prominentere Rolle spielen und auch selbstbewusster geworden sind, werden diese Dinge jetzt seit Jahren immer wieder nach oben gebracht und haben bestimmte Auswirkungen, wie zum Beispiel jetzt diese eine Woche voller Drama und Entlassungen und so weiter.
Zwei Spielerinnen haben da mit der Aslette gesprochen, Sinia Ferrelli und Mana Shim, die sehr detailliert beschrieben haben, wie er ihren Anschuldigen nach seiner Machtposition ausgebraucht hat. Ich will da jetzt gar nicht in die Details einsteigen, ich werde Links in die Show notes packen, wenn es euch interessiert, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Aber das ist jetzt nicht einfach nur alles aus Luftschlössern gebaut. Ich würde mal das Urteil wagen, es gibt wenig Grund zu glauben, dass da Dinge erfunden sind, nachdem auch eine solche Solidarisierungswelle stattgefunden hat und nachdem jetzt auch gehandelt wurde, nachdem es ja schon 2015 einmal eine Beschwerde über ihn gab. Und das war ja das, was du angedeutet hast. Es geht hier mehr um nur isolierte Fälle, sondern es geht um eine Kultur des Verschweigens, des Ablockens und des Nicht-Erns-Nehmens von solchen Vorwürfen.
Ja, und was ich jetzt für dieses Thema besonders interessant finde, und ich habe das auch jetzt diese Woche in einem meiner Artikel über das Thema auch versucht, ein bisschen auszupacken, die Reaktion, die jetzt entstanden ist, ist so schnell wie noch nie. Also würden wir zurückgehen, der erste wirklich prominente Missbrauchsskandal, den gab es im Schwimmen in den USA. Das hat ewig gedauert. Es hat die Hilfe richtig großer Anstrengungen auf der Medienseite, Stichwort Fernsehen, bedurft, um das überhaupt hochzubringen. Und es wurde immer noch so getan, als könnte man das im Grunde ja also gar nicht so ernst nehmen. Es hat dann ein paar Konsequenzen gehabt. Aber es war so, als ob man wirklich Kohle aus der 7. Sohle oder so rausholen muss, ganz tief in den Berg gehen muss. Die zweite Geschichte, die dann passiert ist danach, ist die aus dem Turnen, wo wir halt einen anderen Zuschnitt bekommen haben. Weil wir hatten wirklich einen klaren Täter, der auch überführt wurde und durch viele Aussagen von jungen Mädchen und Frauen wurde die Geschichte hier auch substanziiert. Das war jetzt wirklich kein Einzelfall. Es war nur wieder mal klassisch, was für eine Arbeit da jetzt passieren musste. Das waren hauptsächlich die Kollegen vom Indianapolis Star, die mit Hilfe erster junger Frauen begonnen haben, das aufzudecken. Und dann ging es halt so langsam weiter bis in den strafrechtlichen Bereich. Inzwischen haben wir dann auch die Reaktion auf Seiten des Kongresses in Washington, die etwas, was es schon gab, aber noch nicht richtig funktionierte, dieses Center for Safe Sports in Colorado, das solche Dinge in Angriff nehmen soll und auch dann eventuell Trainer bestrafen, zumindest verbandseitig rausschmeißen usw. Die standen auf sehr wackeligen finanziellen Beinen. Das hat nun die Bundesebene durch den Kongress mit Geld abgefüttert und sie hat gesetzliche Sachen bestimmt, also wie der Sportler zumindest unter dem Dach der olympischen Sportarten, weil da kommt der Kongress dann gerne mit rein, wie die sich verhalten müssen, wenn solche Dinge hochkommen. Also wie sich die Verbände verhalten müssen, was sie melden müssen, dass sie das FBI sofort einschalten müssen usw. Also das war der jüngste große Skandal vor diesem. Und da zeigt sich ja eben eine Entwicklung, dass also die Sensibilität auf Seiten wichtiger Leute gewachsen ist. Und die Drohung, die jetzt zum Beispiel über dem Turnverband schwebt, der ja schon einen Konkurs angemeldet hat, und der so gerade vor wenigen Wochen 400 Millionen Dollar an Schadensersatz angeboten hat gegenüber den betroffenen Frauen und damit schon diesen Betrag um 100 Prozent gedoppelt hat, also 100 Prozent doppelt man ja, und da sind Versicherungen dahinter, die das abdecken wollen, damit dieser Verband wieder aus dem Konkurs rauskommen kann und normal weiterarbeiten kann. Also diese neuen Strömungen, Verhältnisse, dieser Druck, der da mit entstanden ist, dieser politische Druck, den muss man, glaube ich, erwähnen, wenn man verstehen will, was jetzt oder wie jetzt dieses Fußball-Thema sich entwickelt hat.
Dazu ist, glaube ich, noch wichtig zu wissen, die Lage der Liga generell. Es ist jetzt schon der dritte Anlauf, wenn ich richtig gezählt habe, eine Frauen-Fußball-Profiliga zu etablieren. Die NWSL gibt es erst seit wenigen Jahren, weil es eben schon aus finanziellen Gründen mehrmals nicht geklappt hat. Und gleichzeitig haben wir ja die Situation, das darf man auch nicht vergessen, in den USA ist die Frauen-Nationalmannschaft im Fußball bekannter und beliebter als die der Herren. Das WM-Finale 2018 der Männer hatte weniger, eine geringere Einschaltquote, als dasjenige der Frauen. Und dementsprechend starke Stimmen haben wir da auch vertreten, vor allem durch Megan Rapinoe, die ja auch hierzulande bekannt sein dürfte. Und ich lese einfach nur einen Tweet vor, der jetzt auch sehr gerne in der Presse zitiert wurde, der aber, glaube ich, ganz gut das Klima auch darstellt, in dem das alles gerade passiert. Sie hat geschrieben, Men protecting men who are abusing women. I'll say it again, Men protecting men who are abusing women. Ich glaube, das haben alle Hörerinnen und Hörer dann verstanden, wie, ja, deutlich sie sich nicht nur artikuliert, sondern dass das auch so ein bisschen eine Zäsur sein könnte im Frauenfußball in den USA.
Ja, ich hoffe, ich mach das jetzt nicht wieder ein bisschen komplizierter, als es vielleicht ist. Aber einerseits stimmt das. Die Nationalmannschaft ist ein wichtiger Faktor in dem, wir nennen das mal den Vorgang, wie Frauen in bestimmten Sportarten, jetzt im Moment Mannschaftssportarten, auch weiter gewinnen an Popularität, an Sympathien, an Glaubwürdigkeit, dass ihr Sport gut dastehen kann, unter anderem auch wirtschaftlich, zumindest in diesem Nationalmannschaftsrahmen. Weil dort haben diese Frauen, darunter eben Megan und andere, bis hin zu den Verband-Verklagen und solchen Dingen, haben ja auch Dinge schon erkämpft und erreicht. Der Verband stellte sich wie immer doof, als es darum ging zu sagen, Leute, wisst ihr was, wir verdienen genauso viel, wir spielen nicht so viel Geld ein wie die Männer, aber die Männer kriegen irgendwie mehr Geld. Was ist da los? Auch da gab es dann mal Boykottdrohungen, das war dann auch wieder tarifvertraglich nicht wirklich möglich. Dann gab es diese Klage, das haben die Frauen sogar verloren in der ersten Instanz. Aber weil es da jede Menge Mist gab, ist der letzte Präsident dann zurückgetreten, quasi gestolpert über diesen juristischen Vorgang. Und was passiert dann? Eine Frau, Cindy Paolo, als ehemalige Nationalmannschaftsspielerin, das ist natürlich schon einige Jahre her, kommt in die Position der Präsidentin dieses Verbandes. Das heißt also, wir haben auch diesen Kulturwechsel jetzt innerhalb des Fußballs. Was das jetzt genau für den Einzelfall bedeutet, muss man erst mal abwarten. Aber was auffällig ist, der Streit um die Bezahlung scheint bis auf ein paar Details gegessen. Der Verband hat Mitte September gesagt, wir wollen von jetzt ab die Frauen und die Männer gleich, also die Nationalmannschaftsmitglieder, gleich bezahlen als Grundsatzidee. Das ist auch ein Fortschritt. Und den hat diese Gruppe von Frauen, die jetzt nun verstreut ist, innerhalb des Liga-Formats, aber die haben die kompakt, diese 30, 40 Frauen haben das kompakt so weit vorangebracht. Auch das ist Teil der Situation, in der wir uns heute befinden. Und weshalb ich glaube, dass die Dinge jetzt da auch etwa schneller angefasst werden und nicht nur so einfach weggewädelt werden, wie das bisher immer der Fall gewesen ist.
Was man ja noch an einem zweiten Fall auch noch sehen kann, du hast es vorhin schon angesprochen, Kaya McAuliffe hat sich ebenfalls an die Presse gewandt, an die Washington Post, das hattest du auch schon angesprochen. Da geht es um ihren Coach Richie Burke, der, ich würde sagen, emotionale Gewalt gegen sie ausgeübt haben sollen. Der wurde dann ebenfalls entlassen. Wenn ich es richtig nachvollzogen habe, hat sein Verein zunächst behauptet, aus gesundheitlichen Gründen. Und später kamen dann raus, nein, ihre Beschwerde, die sie beim Verein abgegeben hat über ihn, hat dann doch zu seiner Entlassung geführt. Aber das ist eben jetzt auch in ganz enger zeitlicher Abfolge. Ich glaube, das war an einem Tag die eine Nachricht, und am anderen Tag die andere Recherche. Sind eben diese beiden Trainer ihres Traineramtes dann entledigt worden?
Ja, und die Frau, die an der Spitze der Liga stand, Lisa Bärth, war beim Nationalen Olympischen Komitee vor diesem Job in einer Marketing-Rolle oder sowas. Und hat dort auch irgendwie so ein bisschen, wir wissen keine Details, aber gehörte auch zu denen, die gerne alles unter den Teppich kehren wollten. Und die hatte nun eine längere Karriere hinter sich, verschiedene Stationen. Die ist möglicherweise, auch wenn es um die Vermarktung einer Frauen-Fußball-Liga gar nicht schlecht, weil die kämpft ja nun wirklich um die Existenz. Aber wenn das moralisch und ethisch nicht hinhaut, dann muss man sich natürlich von solchen Leuten trennen. Ich will nur sagen, man kann nicht einfach das Personal von Bäumen pflücken und sagen, wir fangen neu an und wir machen alles anders. Das hat man auch schon beim Verband erlebt. Es hat eine Weile gedauert, bis sich diese Dinge weiterentwickeln und so. Insofern gibt es keinen Grund, jetzt Freude klatschend hier zu sitzen und zu sagen, guck mal, es ist ja alles wunderbar. Ich möchte nur gerne diese Entwicklung auch mit herausstreichen. Es ist nicht mehr so dramatisch, wie es mal war. Wir reden hier auch von rein juristisch und deshalb wird das vermutlich auch keine strafrechtlichen Auswirkungen haben. Wir reden hier von erwachsenen Spielern, 18 Jahre und älter. In den Beispielen, die ich vorhin erwähnt habe, Schwimmen und Turnen, reden wir hauptsächlich von Sportlerinnen im Alter von 18 und darunter. Das heißt Minderjährigen. Das heißt, da gibt es auch in den Statuten, in den strafrechtlichen Bestimmungen einzelner Bundesstaaten, wie das ja hier geregelt ist. Wir haben da ein etwas anderes System als in Deutschland, wo die Bundesländer nicht so viel Macht haben. Aber egal, in fast allen Bundesstaaten wird das ähnlich eingestuft. Wer Missbrauch mit Menschen unter 18 ist ein strafrechtliches Thema. Das heißt, wir müssten das auch noch kurz erwähnen. Das, was mit jungen Menschen passiert, deren Einwilligung, selbst wenn man die quasi erwirkt hat, dass sie einwilligen in sexuelle Handlungen oder ähnliches, die ist auf dem Papier gar nichts wert. Weil wenn die Eltern das nicht irgendwie sanktionieren, kann das strafwürdig sein, wenn es dann bewiesen werden kann. Diese Phase hat an allen möglichen Ecken die Leute wachgerüttelt. Und jetzt reden wir mehr von einer Situation, da müssen die Frauen eben dann wirklich auch sich äußern. Sie müssen rauskommen. Sie müssen das zum Thema machen. Und sie müssen es möglichst energisch vertreten. Und jetzt, glaube ich, sind die Chancen besser. Und ich glaube, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, will der Verband oder die Liga auch eine anonyme Telefonnummer einrichten. Anonym heißt, wer sich beschwert, beschwert sich anonym und kann so Dinge nach oben bringen. Keine Ahnung, wie das dann gemanagt wird. Ich hoffe mal in einem positiven Sinne. Aber solche Entwicklungen braucht es vermutlich. Und man kann froh sein, dass wir jetzt schon wenigstens so weit sind.
Also um das kurz noch mal zusammenzufassen, die Liga steht ohne ihre Liga-Chefin da, ohne ihren General Counsel, Lisa Lewine ebenfalls. Es sind zwei Trainer entlassen worden. Es gibt noch eine Reihe von anderen Personalien, die in den letzten Monaten noch aufgefallen sind. Nicht immer hat es auch mit Misshandlungen, manchmal auch mit Sexismus und Rassismus zu tun. Aber generell gab es da jetzt sehr häufig personalen Wechsel. Das meinte ich eben vorhin mit Zäsur, dass es allein personell einen Umbruch gibt, wobei du natürlich Recht hast. Es werden jetzt auch nicht von den Bäumen gleich Personen wachsen, die es so viel besser machen. So wie ich es gelesen habe, will sich die Liga jetzt zusammentun mit einer Stelle, mit einer Organisation, die dabei hilft, dass eben diese Anlaufstelle in einer Art und Weise geschaffen werden kann. Dass eben die Frauen, die sich da melden, eben sowohl wissen, ihr Anliegen wird behandelt und wird eben nicht abgewiesen, so wie es schon zigfach nach dem, was man jetzt lesen konnte, wohl passiert ist, als auch, dass sie persönlich daraus keine direkten Konsequenzen zu befürchten haben. Jetzt haben wir als Journalisten und Journalistinnen ja auch immer das Problem der Verdachtsberichterstattung. Das ist jetzt auch dann schon ein juristischer Begriff, wenn wir von Deutschland ausgehen. Das heißt, wir sprechen eben, du hast es ja vorhin auch schon richtigerweise so eingeordnet, über Vorwürfe, die noch nicht und wahrscheinlich werden sie es in vielen Teilen auch nicht juristisch überprüft nochmal werden. Wie sehr wird denn das in den USA thematisiert und wie schätzt du das selbst ein? Ich möchte jetzt damit nicht sagen, da stimmt etwas nicht, aber gleichzeitig ist es ja unsere Verantwortung, eben auch, ja, verantwortungsvoll darüber zu berichten.
Ich denke, es geht um, in dieser Fragestellung um zwei verschiedene Ebenen. Also es geht erstmal um den Grundsatz generell, der Fairness gegenüber all den Beteiligten, über die man berichten möchte. Und dass man das Thema nicht völlig verschweigt und sagt, was soll es, das interessiert uns doch gar nicht, ist es in Amerika oder sonst welche Gründe. Und wenn man sich dann halt mit diesem Fairness-Gebot beschäftigt, dann kommt man nicht drum herum zu sagen, es gibt zwei Seiten an dieser Geschichte. Erstmal, wir können Informationen anbieten, die das substanzieren, was diese beiden Seiten sagen oder mitteilen. Und dann können wir das Vortragen vorlegen. Und dann können sich die Menschen, die wir jetzt beliefern mit Informationen, können sich ja dann auch ein Bild machen. Und sollten eben versuchen, das zu leisten, was wir nun gar nicht wollen. Wir wollen nicht unbedingt die Schiedsrichter oder die Richter sein. Aber jeder, der gebildet ist und der sich mit Sport, in diesem Fall ja geht es ja um Sport, beschäftigt. Und nachdenken kann und Informationen haben möchte, hat dann anschließend die Chance, die Sache selber zu bewerten. Und das ist ja auch wesentlich. Und der andere Teil ist, wenn wir als Journalisten uns mit solchen Dingen beschäftigen, wir haben eingebaute, also hier sagen wir, Bias, Vorurteile. Wir neigen dazu, bestimmte Autoritäten eher zu akzeptieren und das, was sie sagen. Und das kann manchmal auch sein, dass es der prominentere Sportler ist, dem wir eher glauben. Und es kann aber auch sein, dass wir dem höher rangierenden Menschen eher glauben. Ich meine, du hast mit dem Fall Hoeneß ja ein ganzes, mehr als ein einzelnes Fass. 16 Fässer hast du, glaube ich, aufgemacht.
Ja, es werden jetzt dann, ja mal gucken, ob es bei 16 bleibt.
Und natürlich kommt man nicht umhin zu sagen, okay, Hoeneß hat auch eine Sicht der Dinge oder so. Aber gut, da hatten wir auch einen Prozess und da wurden auch Dinge wirklich jetzt also sehr deutlich und auch sehr klar entschieden. Das Problem haben wir immer und die Frage ist, stellen wir uns aber emotional nicht möglicherweise lieber auf die Seite von Menschen, die schwächer sind in dieser Konstruktion. Und jetzt reden wir von kommerziellen Sport. Und da sind im Zweifel die ganz jungen Athleten oder dann auch die älteren Athleten, die in diesen Abhängigkeitsmechanismen nur existieren können. Und die im Fall der NWSL vielleicht mal gerade 30 bis 40.000 Dollar pro Jahr verdienen und die nebenbei noch bei Zahnärzten das Telefon schmeißen oder bei Amazon die Pakete vollpacken und solche Sachen machen müssen. Und da sollte man natürlich, egal, wie man nun direkt, welche Empfindungen man direkt für Einzelne hat, sollte man sich eigentlich politisch auf jeden Fall auf die Seite dieser Menschen stellen und sagen, ok, Moment mal, das hier können wir nicht einfach ignorieren und am Tisch fallen lassen oder als harmlos runterfahren oder so. Und in Amerika, das war ja deine Frage, funktionieren Medien oft mehr nach dem Grundsatz, also wenn Dinge wirklich neu, spektakulär und auch ein bisschen, wie wir sagen würden, juicy oder sexy sind, weil da, wo Sex eine Rolle spielt, da existiert immer eine höhere Aufmerksamkeit. Es passiert dann doch, dass irgendjemand den Ball ins Rollen bringt und dass das dann aufgegriffen wird von anderen Medien und damit wird das dann ein Thema. Ich sehe mich da eben traditionell auf der Seite der mutmaßlich zu kurz gekommenen, geschädigten, misshandelten und verratenden und verkauften.
Jetzt hast du es ja gerade schon genannt. Die wirtschaftlichen Dimensionen der NWSL sind vielleicht gar nicht so, wie man sich das vorstellt. Du hast das durchschnittliche Jahresgehalt von 30.000 Dollar genannt. Das ist 15.000 unter dem Durchschnittsgehalt der US-Amerikanerinnen und US-Amerikanern. Also sprich, man braucht häufiger noch Nebenjobs mit dazu. Gleichzeitig gab es auch auf Besitzerebene jetzt schon Personalwechsel. Also der Owner, der Besitzer von Washington Spirit, Steve Baldwin, ist zurückgetreten. Nachdem, was man jetzt weiß, wurde er darum gebeten von den Spielerinnen seiner Mannschaft. Was, glaubst du, macht das jetzt mit dieser Liga? Dieser Liga, der ja schon der dritte Versuch ist, den Frauenfußball auf wirtschaftlich solide Fundamente in den USA zu stellen.
Also ich sehe da, was das angeht, weiterhin eher nur dunkle Wolken. Weil, wenn eine Sportart, die sich auf der einen Seite, Stichwort, das haben wir ja schon besprochen, Nationalmannschaft, so gut darstellen kann und so viele Menschen in die Arenen bringt, wenn sie Heimspiele haben und auch hohe Einschaltquoten, wenn es um was geht, wenn da das darunter liegende Gerüst irgendwie nicht stabil laufen kann. Und im Moment läuft das ja nur, weil der Fußballverband die Krämen der Spielerinnen direkt bezahlt. Also die werden gar nicht von der Liga bezahlt. Die bekommen halt ihre besseren Einkünfte von US Soccer und fallen, wenn ich es so sagen darf, der Liga gar nicht wirtschaftlich zur Last. Also diese Konstruktion funktioniert nicht. Ich kann dir nicht genau sagen, warum die nicht mehr Zuschauer und Zuschauerinnen in die Stadien bekommen. Ich kann nachvollziehen, wenn es um die Fernsehrechte geht, das ist ein harter Markt mit vielen verschiedenen Sportarten. Das ist wirklich herbe. Das kann man nicht über Nacht so richtig in den Griff kriegen. Aber wenn es nur um die Resonanz vor Ort geht, da sollte mehr passieren. Nur wenn wir es dann wieder vergleichen mit dem, was Frauenfußball in anderen Ländern in Deutschland, in anderen europäischen Ländern auf die Beine stellt, da sieht es ja auch nicht gerade toll aus. Das Einzige, was da so langsam sich wohl herausschält, korrigiere mich, wenn ich das falsch interpretiere, ist, dass jetzt Clubs wie Bayern München oder Wolfsburg oder andere begreifen, dass sie vielleicht einfach das zu ihrem Thema machen sollten. Und weil sie die großen, starken Fußballinstitutionen sind, auch in der Lage sind, selbst diesen noch nicht ganz gut funktionierenden Teams oder wirtschaftlich funktionierenden Teams ein bisschen unter die Arme greifen können. Weil perspektivisch glaube ich an diese Entwicklung, dass Frauensport mehr Zuschauer bekommt und auch wirtschaftlich funktionieren kann. Es braucht nur ewig lange. Und wir können das aus dem amerikanischen Profi-Männer-Sport wunderbar ableiten. Die National Hockey League, die jetzt schon über 100 Jahre alt ist, war ein furchtbar schlecht gemanagter Laden. Die haben sich im Mitte des 20. Jahrhunderts mit sechs Clubs über Wasser gehalten in den Großstädten. Bis sie dann irgendwann in den 70ern angefangen haben anzubauen, ganz vorsichtig. Die National Football League hat in der Konkurrenz zum College Football, obwohl sie in den 20er Jahren entstanden ist, sie hat so gut wie nichts reißen können. College Football war so populär gegen die Profis. Das hat gedauert, bis das Fernsehen in den 50er Jahren Football mehr und mehr zu einer Fernsehsport gemacht hat und sich bei den Profis auch dann sehr viel mehr reingehängt hat. Bis dahin wurden dann Teams umgezogen von einem Ort in den anderen. Was da auch immer alles passiert ist, wird alles gerne vergessen. Dass auch Männersport, gerade jetzt Mannschaftssport, und das, was außerhalb der Olympischen Spiele gelaufen ist, dass das enorme Anfangsschwierigkeiten gehabt hat. Und dass man das den Frauen auch zubilligen muss, dass sie ein Publikum finden, das sie dann auch tragen hilft.
Und das jetzt ja auf die Straße geht für die Spielerinnen. Also es gab verschiedene Demonstrationen, auch in Stadien bei MLS, also von der Männerliga von Spielen, wo eben viele Transparente zu lesen waren mit Claims in Richtung der NWSL und der Clubbesitzer schützt die Spielerinnen. Das war so ein bisschen das Fazit darunter. Jetzt ist es so, dass wir in den USA, du hast es ja schön beschrieben, das scheint so eine schrittweise Entwicklung zu sein. Und sicherlich kann man es auch nicht davon trennen, dass die MeToo-Bewegung in den USA gestartet ist und da, zumindest meinem persönlichen Empfinden nach, auch den größten Impact hatte. Also hier haben wir eine Entwicklung. Wir haben im Nachbarland, in Kanada, aber ja auch schon einen Missbrauchsfall gehabt, beziehungsweise mehrere, worüber du auch schon berichtet hast. Auch diesen Bericht im Deutschlandfunk war das, werde ich nochmal in den Show Notes verlinken. Lass mal den Blick ein bisschen lösen von den USA. Wie glaubst du denn, jetzt anhand dieses kanadischen Beispiels sieht die Situation anderswo aus?
Also anhand des kanadischen Beispiels ist ja aufgefallen, und ich habe dir ja den Tweet geschickt, in der der kanadische Verband so einen Solidartweet gegenüber den Freunden südlich der Grenze abgesetzt hat. Klar, ich verstehe das, das ist das kleinere Land, aber im Fußball ist ja alles hier auf diesem Kontinent klein. Und die haben zusammen eine Weltmeisterschaft jetzt demnächst und so. Also die wollen sich da irgendwie anbiedern, keine Ahnung. Aber dann hat halt eine der Frauen, die diesen alten Fall mit Macht versucht, nach wie vor am Leben zu halten, wo Trainer nach wie vor im Einsatz sind und nicht abgeurteilt wurden, nicht mal intern, disziplinarisch oder so weiter. Die hat das dann natürlich, also Ciara McCormick hat das also gleich den Finger genau da drauf gelegt. Diese, wie wollen wir das nennen, entweder dumme oder zynische Haltung von Leuten, die ihre eigene Geschichte nicht kennen, die also eigentlich mal dringend anfangen sollten, in ihrem eigenen Laden aufzuräumen und die vermutlich auch nur Lippenbekenntnisse abgeben und die nicht wirklich daran interessiert sind, da anzupacken, wo sie anpacken könnten. Das ist ja das Schöne. Man kann ja so richtig schön über den Zaun winken und sagen, okay.
Ja, und sie haben ja eine Forderung aufgestellt. Sie haben nicht nur gesagt, wir solidarisieren uns mit den Spielerinnen, sondern sie haben gesagt, we expect full accountability, also da die entsprechenden Menschen sollen zur Verantwortung gezogen werden, zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden.
Und gut, man kann hoffen, dass vielleicht jetzt so etwas dann auch wiederum, wahrscheinlich geht es nur über die Medien, in den kanadischen Medien, wo es leider nicht so viele Zeitungen gibt, aber eine sehr ordentliche Fernsehgesellschaft und Radiogesellschaft, Canadian Broadcasting Corporation, also vergleichbar zu dem, was in Deutschland mit dem Öffentlich-Rechtlichen existiert. Da kann man nur hoffen, dass das irgendwie dort Leute wachrüttelt. Und das ist nicht mal nur so am Hemd, an den Hemdknöpfen abgezählt, weil zum Beispiel in der Eishockey-Thematik, die natürlich den Kanadiern viel näher liegt, sind auch sehr viele Missbrauchsaspekte, inklusive Gesundheit und alles Mögliche, inzwischen intensiv von den Medien aufgegriffen worden. Und da sieht man auch, dass die Sensibilität der weiten Teile der sportinteressierten Bevölkerung wächst. Und ich glaube, die Sache dreht sich immer da im Kreis, wo man so tun kann, als interessiert das doch gar keinen. Das sind doch nur so ein paar hundert oder tausend Aktive, die können nicht mal sich selber ernähren oder so. Was wollt ihr? Und dann gibt es Männer, die die halt ein bisschen antreiben und hart anfassen oder so. Das müssen die doch in Kauf nehmen. Was wollen die eigentlich? Also wenn es aus diesem Blickwinkel rausgerissen werden kann und wirklich auf die Ebene von Gleichbehandlung, Gleichwertigkeit, Respekt, was immer auch wir unter Menschenrechtsrubriken so an Begriffen haben, wenn das also mal stattfindet, ist das vielleicht auch für Kanada eine Chance. Wie das dann aber in anderen Ländern aussieht, das weiß ich nicht. Ich habe mich jetzt nicht beschäftigt mit Dingen, die in Deutschland existieren. Oder im Fußball speziell nicht. Oder auch der englische Frauenfußball kommt da jetzt gut an zu laufen. Der französische Frauenfußball funktioniert da ganz gut. Also ich weiß nicht, was da gerade so los ist. Möglicherweise hast du da mal kurz dich informiert.
Ja gut, wir hatten ja auch hier im deutschen Sport, das war ja auch, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, im Deutschlandfunk und WDR, hat dazu glaube ich eine Doku gemacht, hatten wir auch, zum Teil aus dem Fußball, es ging aber auch um den Reitsport, hatten wir auch Missbrauchsfälle, die aufgekommen sind. Aber es geht dann immer nichts voran. Es wird darüber berichtet, es ehrlicherweise in einer gewissen Reichweite übersteigt es auch nie. Wahrscheinlich würde sich das dann auch an den Juicy Details, die du vorhin genannt hast, orientieren. Plus wahrscheinlich an der Prominenz sowohl der Sportarten als auch der entsprechenden Sportler und Sportlerinnen, die da betroffen sind. Aber das wäre jetzt eben meine Frage gewesen, ob du etwas siehst in der Aufarbeitung, die jetzt gerade in den USA passiert, die hoffentlich dann auch irgendwann in Kanada passiert, woran man sich orientieren könnte, auch in Deutschland und Europa. Denn es gibt ja eigentlich keinen Grund zu glauben, dass nur auf anderen Kontinenten Männer ihre Machtposition gegenüber schutzbedürftigen Frauen und Mädchen und auch Jungen und Männern genauso ausnutzen, wie es da drüben passiert ist. Gibt es da Dinge, die du im Kopf hast?
Also mir ist nur aufgefallen, dass im Bundestag, nun hatten wir gerade Wahlen und alle stellen sich neu auf und wir wissen noch nicht mal, wie die Koalition die nächste aussehen wird und wer Bundeskanzler wird. Aber wenn wir das mal wegschieben für einen Augenblick. Der Sportausschuss im Bundestag, den ich so aus der Ferne immer mal wieder beobachte, das ist so ein lahmer Laden, der ist eben nicht die Pressure Group für die Aktiven, für die Betroffenen, für die Schutzwürdigen. Das ist die Pressure Group schlechthin der Lobbyarm der Verbandsfunktionäre, die also dort auch teilweise reingerutscht sind über irgendwelche Präsidentenjobs, die sie im Sport hatten und die dann in die Politik gegangen sind. Weil sie dann angeblich Kompetenz haben, dann kriegen sie halt diesen Sportausschussplatz zugewiesen. Da gibt es zig Beispiele von Leuten, die da null Interesse entwickelt haben, genau solche Themen anzupacken und an besten Fall sich verstehen als Lobbyisten, die versuchen, aus dem Bundeshaushalt möglichst viel Geld für den medallienträchtigen Sport herauszuweisen. Weshalb wir solche Dinge haben, die wir sonst nirgendwo auf der Welt haben. Oder nur früher in der Sowjetunion, in der DDR, irgendwelche Soldaten und Polizisten, die also da gut geparkt werden und auf Steuerkosten ihren Sport betreiben. Das ist das Einzige, was die da wirklich hingekriegt haben. Unser System von Förderungseinrichtungen, Akademien und so weiter, die sie ein bisschen unterstützen. Und wenn man sich anguckt, wie gerade zum Beispiel der DOSB nicht funktioniert, der zwar sicherlich jetzt für den Fußball keine Rolle spielt, aber für viele andere Sportarten ja durchaus, dann sehen wir ja doch auf einen Blick, da ist doch so viel im Argen, da weiß man ja gar nicht, wo man anfangen soll. Also, wenn die Politik tatsächlich sich so entschieden einbringen würde, wie das in den USA passiert ist, dann, glaube ich, könnte man Fortschritte auch woanders sehen. Aber hier ist die Politik oft auch Marketing. Also die Leute, diese Politiker, die sich dann da hinsetzen und vor den Live-Kameras von Seaspendern so ihre Anliegen ausbreiten und Anhörungen durchziehen und so weiter, die haben auch ein Interesse, die sind jetzt nicht völlig, das sind keine Heiligen.
Die machen das auch für den Schnipsel, der dann über Social Media geht, wenn jemand eine besonders schlaue Frage gestellt hat.
Und die können zeigen, dass sie sich zumindest für Schwache einsetzen, was erst mal sympathisch rüberkommt. Das könnte man im Bundestag auch. Aber so weit meine Einschätzung nach ist das nicht. Und deshalb bin ich mal skeptisch, wenn ich darf.
Also ich werde auch da noch mal Links in die Shownotes packen. Ich habe es noch mal nachgeguckt im Mai 2019, dass im Deutschlandfunk da unter anderem eine Frau ihr Schweigen gebrochen hat. Das waren ganz, ganz erschütternde Dinge, die sie da erzählt hat. Ab ihrem 10. Lebensjahr wurde sie von Betreuung ihrer Fußballmannschaft sexuell missbraucht. Da braucht man einen starken Magen, um das zu hören. Deine Erfahrung nach dem, wie du es jetzt in den USA erlebt hast, da sind ja auch nicht alle Politikerinnen sofort zu Handlungen gekommen. Du hast ja auch beschrieben, wie das jetzt ja auch eine unterschiedliche Geschwindigkeit hatte bei den unterschiedlichen Fällen. Es muss wahrscheinlich zuerst der öffentliche Aufstrahl und die Medienberichterstattung da sein, bevor es strukturelle Veränderungen gibt?
Das ist das eine. In den Fällen, in denen dann zum Beispiel aus diesen Anschuldigungen heraus auch Schadenersatzklagen entstehen, die also nichts mit der strafrechtlichen Seite zu tun haben, sondern nur mit der Frage, sind dort Menschen zu Schaden gekommen? Und sehen die existierenden Gesetze so etwas wie eine Wiedergutmachung vor? Das ist eine besondere Spezialität des amerikanischen Rechts. Das wird sogar mit einem unverständlichen Begriff belegt, den ich jetzt gar nicht zitieren möchte, damit wir nicht auch noch darüber reden müssen. Dieses Verständnis von Rechtswesen und Rechtssystem ist ganz wichtig nachzuzeichnen, weil man dann erkennt, dass zumindest, sobald Anwälte sich dieser Anliegen annehmen und diese Anwälte arbeiten, meistens nach dem Prinzip, das es hier auch erlaubt, dass sie, wenn Geld, also sie verlangen gar kein Geld, aber wenn sie Geld heraushandeln oder durch Prozesse herausprozessieren können, bekommen sie einen relativ hohen Anteil an dem dann herausgehandelten Geld. Also sie gehen voll ins Risiko und sagen, dieser Fall liegt gut. Ich glaube, wir kommen hier irgendwie weiter. Das ist also ein Teil des amerikanischen Rechtswesens und ein wichtiger Baustein an vielen Stellen, der Dinge verändern kann. Reden wir noch mal kurz über einen anderen Aspekt des Fußballs, nämlich Gehirnerschütterung und die Frage sind Kopfbälle ein Teil des Problems. Auch das Thema ist in den USA hauptsächlich über das Rechtswesen und über eine Klage gegen die FIFA und den US-Verband abgeschmettert. Aber die Klage selber hat in den USA sehr viel Bewegung gebracht und der Verband hat sich dann irgendwann zumindest eine kleine Reform ausgedacht. Also die Altersbegrenzung für Kopfballtraining eingeführt. Also das ist ein Teil des amerikanischen Phänomens. Und wenn dann auf diesen Zug, der dann schon mal irgendwie läuft, dann noch die Politiker draufsteigen und damit drohen, die haben wirklich viel Macht, die können Leute vor ihre Ausschüsse ziehen und sagen, ihr müsst hier unter AID aussagen. Und wenn ihr hier unter AID lügt, dann habt ihr ein ganz anderes Problem. Dann kommt ihr nämlich wegen mein AID eventuell dran. Das heißt also diese Stelle in der Entwicklung ist auch sehr amerikanisch und kann in anderen Ländern eigentlich nur durch sehr viel Initiative und Energie auch irgendwie mitgeleistet werden. Das macht es hier manchmal so, als ob es einfacher aussieht. Aber das Geröll, das hier bewegt werden muss, ist oft viel größer. Die Felsen, die hier rumliegen und die alle irgendwie bewegen wollen. Also insofern kann man jetzt nicht sagen, ein Loblied auf Amerika oder die Vereinigten Staaten und alles super. Aber bestimmte Mechanismen können manchmal auch wirklich etwas bewegen. Und dann eben auch Gesetze entstehen lassen.
Genau. Ich glaube, allein das darüber reden ändert schon etwas. Und nur um die Dimension klarzumachen. Es gab eine Kommission zur Aufarbeitung von sexuellem Kindesmissbrauch. Da geht es jetzt nur um Kinder. Und die Vorsitzende Sabine Andresen hat damals bei der Vorstellung dieses Kommissionsberichts, das war eben auch 2019 gesagt, der sexuelle Missbrauch im Umfeld des Sports könnte ähnliche Dimensionen haben wie in der Kirche. Und es ist schon interessant, dass wir ganz, ganz viele Geschichten hören über die Kirche. Da tut sich auch leider überhaupt gar nichts. Da könnte ich jetzt auch meinen ganz eigenen Rund starten. Den verspare ich mir an dieser Stelle. Aber dass es da jemanden gibt, der sich mit diesem Thema ausführlichst beschäftigt hat und die sagt, ja wir vermuten im Sport ist es genauso schlimm wie in der Kirche, da kann man dann doch schon mal die Frage stellen, warum wird in der Kirche so wenig sich da tut, aber warum wird da so viel darüber berichtet? Warum ist das so auch tief in den Köpfen vieler Menschen vereidigt? Ich kenne viele Leute, die deshalb aus der Kirche ausgetreten sind. Und ich finde, das ist auch ein guter Grund, um aus der Kirche auszutreten. Diese Debattenkultur oder diesen Debattenstatus würde ich mir auch für den Sport wünschen, dass es einfach normaler ist, das mit auf dem Schirm zu haben. Denn das wiederum würde dann auch wieder hoffentlich die ausstrahlende Wirkung haben. Das Missbrauch gerade im Bereich von Kindern, müssen ja die Erwachsenen die Augen offen halten, dass da vielleicht auch Dinge mal verhindert werden. Es braucht ein Bewusstsein dafür. Ich weiß, dass ich mich jetzt ein bisschen anhöre wie ein Prediger, aber in diese Richtung müsste es gehen.
Ich glaube, wenn wir uns ein bisschen mit der Geschichte von solchen kulturellen Entwicklungen beschäftigen, können wir erkennen, dass dieser Status der katholischen Kirche über ein rechtlich wirksames Papier, wie das Konkordat, auch abgesegnet und so weiter, eine historisch gewachsene Geschichte ist. Das heißt, die stehen da als diese glaubwürdigen, halb unantastbaren Personen. Denen etwas nachzuweisen, ist fast doppelt so schwer wie irgendjemanden, der gerade mal im Supermarkt was hat mitgehen lassen oder der schwarz fährt oder so. Und was ich glaube, ist, wenn man jetzt den Sport in seiner Ganzheit mit dem vergleicht, was die katholische Kirche zum Beispiel über 2000 Jahre sich erarbeitet hat, da ist der Sport natürlich noch nicht so weit. Aber der Sport ist permissiver. Das heißt, da kommen also allen dauernd immer wieder junge Leute mit rein, immer wieder neue Eltern mit rein, die sich auch entwickelt haben, die auch irgendwie im Geistes der jeweiligen Zeit groß geworden sind und die auch Erwartungen haben und auch Kontrollmechanismen sehen wollen. Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass zum Beispiel Schulen sich weiterentwickeln, dass sich Eltern an Schulen stärker einbringen, als sie das bisher getan haben, wo sie weder Lust oder Zeit hatten, sich darum zu kümmern und froh waren, wenn die Kinder gut behandelt wurden und mit guten Noten nach Hause kamen. Nicht, dass ich behaupte, in den Schulen ist gerade ganz viel missbrauchlos oder so. Aber da gab es früher zum Beispiel, da durften Kinder in der Schule geschlagen werden. Das wurde auch irgendwann mal beendet. Auch das ist ein Bereich, in dem man nicht vergessen sollte. Wir wollten nur über den Sport reden. Es ist ja auch okay, sich darauf zu beschränken. Es ist ja immer noch ein weites Feld.
Es ist ein weites Feld. Es wird auch nicht das letzte Mal im Rasenfunk besprochen worden sein. Aber ich fand das jetzt sehr schön, von diesem einen speziellen Fall ins Allgemeine zu kommen. Ich danke dir ganz herzlich. Jürgen Kalwa, liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer, folgt ihm auf Twitter. Dort heißt er at American Arena. Er hat auch verschiedene Bücher geschrieben. Das letzte war zu Dirk Nowitzki. Soweit so gut. Oder es war doch das letzte, oder? Bei dir ist es gar nicht so einfach, immer dran zu bleiben. Das war das letzte.
Das war das letzte. Demnächst soll wieder eins rauskommen. Wir können ja dann, wenn es so weit ist, nochmal überreden.
Ja, sehr gut.
Aber Dirk Nowitzki passte auch wunderbar zu dem Ende seiner Karriere. Das war nicht ganz leicht, das zu timen. Aber er hat uns dann den Gefallen getan, auch tatsächlich aufzuhören. Wir dachten, er würde aufhören. Das war so ein Versuch, ein Thema, in dem Fall die sportliche Geschichte einer Person so umfassend wie möglich anzupacken. Das sollten wir weiterhin tun, egal welches Thema, egal wann du Lust hast.
Das machen wir. Jürgen, ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst.
Ich war sehr happy hier. Ich freue mich gerne wieder, wenn ich darf.
Ja, darfst du jederzeit. Und damit auch herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Der Rasenfunk ist werbepaywall und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns allein über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Bitte tut das auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da könnt ihr erfahren, wie ihr das im Detail machen könnt. Und ansonsten freue ich mich, wenn ihr bald wieder einschaltet, wenn ihr uns weiterempfehlt und wenn ihr uns auch gerne weiter eure Aufmerksamkeit schenkt. Bis dahin, bleibt gesund, passt auf euch auf. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.